[Music]
the upcoming game of thrones prequel
sirius house of the dragon is based on
the george rr martin's targaryen history
book fire and blood
house of the dragon is a game of thrones
prequel show that is confirmed by hbo's
president to air in 2022
miguel sapochnick and ryan condell will
serve as show runners and
executive producers george r martin will
also serve as executive producer
it's based on george rr martin's
targaryen history book firing blood
volume 1
and on martin's yet unfinished firing
blood volume 2 book
fire and blood begins their tale with
the legendary aegon the conqueror
creator of the armed throne and goes on
to recount the generations of targaryens
who fought to hold that iconic seat
all the way up to the civil war that
nearly tore their dynasty apart
in other words it covers events from
aegon's conquest to the dance of the
dragons
that's fire and blood volume 1. the aton
released fire and blood vol 2 will
continue from where part 1
ended with rhinera targaryen's son aegon
iii
reign and will cover blackfyre
rebellions the war with dorne and go all
the way to the mad king
and robert's rebellion attended
targaryen dynasty
when people speak about aegon's conquest
people always speak how it's aegon and
his sister wives rhaenyra and with zegna
who conquered and united the seven
kingdoms
but they forget to mention their
half-brother born out of wedlock
or is baratheon son of aryan targaryen
oris played
just as big role in aegon's conquest he
might not have ridden a dragon which he
most certainly would have
if there had been a fourth dragon as he
was the blood of a dragon himself
but he commanded aegon's armies on the
ground as aegon the conqueror
said it himself oris was his shield his
stalwart his strong right hand
why was oryis a baratheon and not a
targaryen you may ask
valoris and aegon had the same father
aryan targaryen
but different mothers and unlike aegon's
mother
oris's mother did not vet their father
therefore orris could not get the
targaryen surname as he was born out of
wedlock
how and why the doris get baratheon's
surname is unknown
but it's likely that baratheon's surname
was used in valyria for children born
out of wedlock like snow
sand and a few more are used for
children born out of
adlock investors lord doris baratheon
was the founder of house baratheon
and was half brother of king aegon the
first targaryen
that's right first baratheon was blood
of the dragon half targaryen himself
oris was one of aegon's fiercest
commanders and was regarded as aegon's
only true friend and champion of his
youth
during the war of conquest he was a
commander in the army of fagon the
conqueror
when aegon invaded vestrios he sent oris
to seed storm's end
the ancestral seat of the storm kings
and capital of the stormlands
oris defeated the storm king argu lagged
the arrogant and took not only storm's
end
but also his sigil the crowned black
stag
and words ours is the fury as well as
his daughter arjula
and his sword to cement his rule over
the stormlands
he became the first lord paramount of
aureus is also considered the first hand
of the king
serving gig on the conqueror famed for
his prowess in battle his commanding
skills
and his strong loyalty to king aegon the
first and house targaryen
ortiz was described as a fierce warrior
fighting for house targaryen during
aegon's conquest
the first dornish more and the vulture
hunt
being the founder of house baratheon
auris baratheon is the distant ancestor
of king robert baratheon and his
brothers
stannis and renly oris had black hair
and black eyes
as well as black beard in game of
thrones if you paid close attention you
could notice that he has an
entry in the lineages and histories of
the great houses of the seven kingdoms
it reveals soros's marriage to argela
and that one of his sons died
stopping an assassination attempt
against the son of his half-brother
aegon the conqueror
king gaine is targaryen little is known
about his youth
but what is known is that oryis was
aegon's champion
when king argually randon offered aegon
his daughter arjuna in marriage and some
lands as her dowry
the lord of dragonstone aegon spurned
the storm king's proposal
instead he requested significantly more
land and offered to seal the pact by
wetting auris to argilec's daughter
the storm king angrily rejected these
terms for argue like the arrogant
believed that this was supposed to be an
insult for horus
might have been aegon's brother and have
targaryen blood
but torres was born out of wedlock and
the storm king viewed such a match would
dishonor his daughter
anger that the insult of being offered a
man born out of adlock instead of a king
argilac cut off the hands of aegon's
envoys
when aegon's conquests had begun oris
had command on the ground during the
first battle
defeating lords mutant and darkling oris
led the army while aegon attacked from
the skies
after aegon's coronation at aegon fort
orys was raised to hand of the king
within days of the coronation orys and
queen rhaenys targaryen with her dragon
miraxis were then tasked
with capturing storm's end taking the
greater part of fagon's host with them
while king argilac gathered his banners
lord sveld buckler and errol ambushed
the advanced elements of oris's host
until they were forced to retreat and
marxist burned the surrounding woods
argue like the arrogant hearing of the
burning of harrenhal
knew his formidable walls would not
protect him from dragonfire
argilac rode out with his great host to
give open battle and die with a sword in
hand
orys was made of heir of argelic's marge
by rhaenys
who provided him with the storm king's
numbers and dispositions
for she had spotted the host with her
dragon baratheon took up a strong
position on the hills south of
bronzegate
digging in on the high ground while he
evaded the stormlanders
argelek's host was twice the size of
oriss and when the battle called the
last storm begun
the stormlanders managed to break
through the baratheon's center
only to be engulfed by dragonflame with
mercies and reigneys turning the battle
into chaos
or is descended down the hill where he
encountered the storm
king ordering his own men to stand aside
he gave argilac a chance to yield
argilac
cursed stories and they fought instead
although he took wound or is slow argue
like the arrogant ending the reign of
the storm kings
the loss of their king made the
stormlanders surrender or flee
after the battle argella the random the
daughter of argilac
declared herself the storm queen and
continued to hold storm's end until her
household
turned against her to avoid the same
fate of harrenhal
they delivered her to worries naked and
chained
oris however covered her with his cloak
and treated her chivalrously
aegon rewarded oris with the lands and
incomes of storm's
end and named him lord paramount of the
stormlands
none dared to suggest that he was
unworthy of these honors
oris to cardiologize his wife and to
honor argilac's valor he adopted the
stag banner
honors and words of the durandans ours
is the fury
forming house baratheon oris later
joined
king aegon the first in the first
dornish war in 4ac
leading an assault on the boneway with 1
000 pig knights
his horses struggled up the stony narrow
and twisty paths
while his knights were hit with boulders
from above the work of defenders the
stormlanders never saw
cunning dornishmen then launched a night
raid raining arrows rocks and spears
from above as the stormlanders crossed
the bridge
bodies of the invading army blocked the
bone wave from both ends
and then lordoris ordered his men to
fall back
a triggered rock fall cut off their
retreat with no way forward or back the
stormlanders were massacred
saved for oris and a dozen other lords
thought worth the ransom
however oris and his bannermen found
themselves the captives of the veil of
will
the savage mountain lord called the
widow lover when aegon eventually agreed
to the dornish ransom demands lord
baratheon and his bannermen were
ransomed in 7ac
for each men's weight in gold however
they were afraid only after having their
sword hands chopped off
so they would not be able to use them
again against dorne
thereafter oris became known as zorris
one hand
in retaliation for this treachery king
aegon descended on the mountain fastness
of house will
with his dragon valerian and burn them
to rubble although the wills managed to
take refuge in their caves and tunnels
beneath the mountains
after the loss of his hand in the first
dornish war ories became bitter
turning his attention to dorne and
obsessed with the idea of revenge
he resigned his office as hand and
returned to the stormlands
while resigning he is set to aegon the
king's hand should have a hand
i will not have men speaking of king's
stump he became obsessed with vengeance
against the dornish especially house
well
whose lord had removed his hand vampire
says dieria martel came to king's
landing to provide peace terms
lord doris argued for sending the
princess back to her father nymore the
prince of dorne without a hand
but aegon made peace with dorne instead
oris received his opportunity for
vengeance against the villas
in the second dornish war during the
early reign of aegon's son
king gaines the first targaryen in 37ac
a dornish outlaw
known as the vulture king led a huge
army to reeve the lands north of the red
mountains
the vulture king split his host having
one half led by lord walter well
the lord of storms and orys eager for
revenge against the dornish led his
forces from storm's end one last time to
participate in the vulture hunt
while will's host sat besieging
stonehelm
oys's forces crushed the dornish man
beneath the walls of the castle
lord walter will the son of will who
chopped off or is his hand was brought
to worse
wounded but still alive your father took
my hand
i claim your says repayment or he said
to him but he took
far more lord baratheon chopped off
walter's sword hand
then his other hand followed by both
feet which he called his usury or in
other words his prolonged revenge
with interest at unreasonably high rates
on his trip home to storm zen legendary
oris died of the wounds he had taken in
the battle
or his died content according to his son
davos smiling that he got his revenge
or his baratheon blood of the dragon
played a huge role in aegon's conquest
and is one of the most important
characters from this time period
an honorable man who upholds his loyalty
to his half-brother aegon
and whose prowess in battle was greater
even of that of fagon himself
which he proved in the war against the
last storm king and whose commanding
skills earned aegon to conquer
quite a few important victories in
westeros can we just take a moment to
say that this baratheon crown suits
henry cavill very well
huge strong man with black hair and good
swordsmanship
like a true baratheon just perfect
choice for aries baratheon
thank you so much for watching if you
enjoyed this video please give it a big
thumbs up and i hope to see you in the
next one
peace